Joining me today is the author of the
orphan x novels,
a comic book writer whose work includes
Batman,
Wolverine,
and the punisher,
and a guy trying to save the Democrats.
Gregg Hurwitz.
Has It gone?
It's good to see you.
That's the scariest one.
You can write all the thriller novels
you want to in gallery.
It's worse than any Batman Villain or
evil theory I've ever heard.
Trying to save the Democrats,
but you're trying.
We're going to get to that in a little
bit.
So there's a lot I want to do here with
you.
Uh,
let's talk or if an experts and a little
bit just about your work.
Um,
what got you into thrillers?
You know,
the only thing I ever wanted to do is
write thrillers.
And my parents did not let me watch TV
when I was growing up in Leicester was
Alfred Hitchcock movie on or the Red Sox
were on my dad's from Boston.
So that was religion.
Um,
and so all that I did was read.
And so I was like climbing the
bookshelves to get to,
you know,
jaws on the top shelf.
And Stephen King,
I mean I was just into all that stuff
by,
by fifth grade and I was obsessed with
it and I still remember reading Salem's
lot,
like under my bed with a flashlight.
I was 25 years old,
but my parents were out and I remember
just being terrified and just thinking
it's,
it's insane to me that this guy,
Stephen King can take a combination of
familiar words and put them together in
an unfamiliar way and elicit this much
emotion in me and just the only thing I
wanted to do.
So I started to write these mysteries
with like crown illustrations at that
age.
And I went to college,
studied English and psychology.
That's where I met Jordan because I
thought that'd be the best combination
of majors.
And I started my first novel when I went
to Harvard.
I went to Harvard.
Yeah.
Say College.
You could,
you could say that place in Canberra.
Um,
and so basically I started my first book
when I was 19 and then it got supremely
lucky and sold it,
you know,
and kind of never had to have a real
job.
Yeah.
Does that,
is that how it feels to you still have a
real job?
Like when I was just looking through
your wikipedia today and all the cool
things that you've done and all the
comic books that I've grown up,
you know,
reading and the characters that
everybody cares about.
It doesn't.
It doesn't feel real.
I can't believe I get paid to do it.
Like I love it so much.
I sort of wake up and float down the
hall to my office on a barge of
gratitude.
I just,
it's so great.
And the comics were a blast.
I mean the comics are like when you get
into marvel and DC,
it's like that super rich kid who used
to live up the street from.
You had all the best toys and you could
go to their house and play with their
toys.
That's more vul in DC.
It's like,
do you want to.
I still remember my first call for
marvel.
I'm the editor in chief who's,
who's a very good friend.
Axel Alonso was a fan of some of my
books and called and said you can have
sort of any character from the marvel
volts.
Oh Man.
And it had to be super calm and cool and
collected,
but my inner geek boy,
he's doing cartwheels.
I mean,
I know you love this stuff and it's like
it's in our cells.
And so I said know I wanted to do the
punisher because the punisher was the
end all be all.
There's a lot of punisher in orphan acts
too.
I mean you can a lot of Batman,
you can see those and basically I wound
up writing that they wanted someone from
outside of Comex because garth ennis had
completed his legendary run and they
wanted to kind of reboot it and I still
remember I had this totally surreal
experience where I went to the bookstore
right here on Ventura.
I'm sorry,
the comic book shop and I could no
longer buy my favorite comment because I
was writing it like I already knew what
would have happened in it and it was
completely real comic book in there.
So when I was wild.
Yeah.
So are you more of a marvel guy or a DC
guy to ask?
I don't know that you legally can answer
that.
You're more marvel.
Yeah.
I'm more of a more.
I am more marvel with the exception of
Batman.
I mean I love whole spider.
I was hardcore spider man,
like you know,
and I had every punisher appearance
would make of sort of the way the movies
have gone down because it's so clear
that marvel has figured out how to do
these movies correctly and at least from
my opinion,
dc or the wonder woman,
the standalone.
It was good.
Like they just can't quite get right.
Although the,
the original Batman,
the Christian Bale,
Batman's,
where will those Batman's?
So I wrote Batman the dark night,
do you have here?
So my Batman series,
it was very much has an homage to those
films.
It wasn't the main Batman title,
just Batman was Batman the dark night
and I was very focused on reinventing
the villains.
I love villains and I love dealing with
darkness and giving them a very
legitimate viewpoint,
which is probably part of the
perspective shifting that I think that
I'm capable of doing politics.
I can see a lot of other sides and a lot
of valid reasons for it.
Well,
I can also see this is why you can do
some things with Jordan because he
always talks about you have to give the
devil his due and I guess you really
have to do that if you're going to write
a good villain,
right?
No.
Yeah.
I mean the bad guy never thinks he's the
bad guy.
Right?
So it's like the more I think younger
writers and me included,
you know,
my early stuff,
it's like the worst possible serial
killer villain you think that makes your
guy a better force for good.
And what you realize is if you can
actually build a steel man instead of a
straw man,
like someone who has a reason,
rationale and worldview that we almost
start to relate to as a villain,
like it's right there.
And then your guy defeats him even
through that chaos and ambiguity,
um,
that actually occurs way more positively
to your protagonist than if he's just
tracking serial killers all day.
Serial killer is inherently aren't that
interesting from a narrative perspective
because it's like,
why do you do it?
Oh,
he's insane.
You know,
if you can find people with a real
rationale,
which is what I do for,
it's what I really do in the orphan
access.
But I did that with penguin,
with scarecrow,
with,
you know,
the mad hatter.
I tried to give them an inner life that
shows the reflection of Batman.
It's sorta like a buffalo bill.
Wasn't really the interesting bad guy.
Silence of the lambs.
It was Hannibal Lecter,
right?
Like the psychopath.
There were the straight up murdering
psychopath.
Yeah.
It was more about the intricacies of the
psychological piece.
Well,
and that structured like a love story.
Right?
That's a love story between Hannibal
Lecter and clarice starling.
Right.
Didn't end that well for well.
Well for them it did.
For them it did.
I didn't end that well for the guy to
jail.
There's a dance and there was a
flirtation and so it's very much about
them,
you know,
it's just very weird,
twisted foray into intimacy between two
opposite parties.
And so it's structured out like a
romance.
We should recut cut that as a Romcom
sure.
Somebody,
somebody's done that on youtube
somewhere.
So for somebody that's interested in
stories and these archetypal characters,
and as you know,
I'm on tour with Jordan Peterson right
now.
Um,
how much truth do you think people can
get out of these stories because Jordan
is always talking about,
you know,
the truth that you can extrapolate from
religious stories,
but then also it does related that you
can get truth from well written fiction,
like,
you know,
he talks about Harry Potter a lot or the
story of Pinocchio or just different
things when you're writing these things.
Are you really keeping that in mind?
Yeah,
you know,
that's a really interesting question.
I mean,
I,
I believe I'm a hardcore young yet.
I mean,
I first studied young under Jordan,
my,
my thesis,
if anybody,
like if Ambien doesn't work,
my thesis was 14 and young in analysis
of shakespearian tragedy.
I mean I pause it that Shakespeare was.
His tragedies are like perfect
thrillers,
right?
They're highly structured,
convention bound,
reinterpretations of past themes that
are narratively driven of lust,
intrigue and murder designed to appeal
to the broadest possible cross section
of people.
But I'm a hardcore young Ian and that I
do believe that the hero myth is as
essential and evolutionarily selected as
opposable thumbs and eyelids.
Like you can find a tribe cut off from
all human contact very deep in the
Amazon and you know they're going to
have opposable thumbs.
You know,
they're going to have eyelids and you
know that they're going to have a hero
myth with all the constituent parts.
So then the question is,
well,
why?
And so what I believe is that,
I mean,
what I believe,
what,
what young believes,
what Jordan talks about a lot is that
there's essential wisdom that's
embedded.
That in my mind is more,
is a more real truth.
And the truth is that we deal with on
the surface and a lot of ways of how to
contend with the unknown,
both internally and externally.
So you buy in.
If we were looking at the Sorta Sam
Harris Jordan debate on this,
you buy Jordan's version of that,
that it's beyond just fact that can give
us truth.
It's that there has to be some other
sort of story on top of that.
Yes.
I think we're story processing and story
making machines that you can't get value
out of just fact alone basically.
Yeah.
I mean you need to.
You need to embed something in some
archetypal structure.
So I always think of it like we're
preconditioned to have.
And you know,
it's complicated because people think
when you talk about the end collective
unconscious people think that like
somewhere floating in our prefrontal
cortex is the notion of a whiz into old
woman as representing wisdom.
But I don't think it's that.
I think that there's a story engine that
is selected that drives people to say,
okay,
I need a representation for wisdom.
So if you look around your village or
your city or your community,
that will tend to land on somebody who's
older,
like it's ingrained in them.
So there's different choices that
happen.
I don't believe that,
that there is sort of essential
specifics that are floating in our head,
but the mechanism to make,
to make meaning,
um,
he's in there and the mechanism to look
at different things that are in the
world around us and the plugin symbols
and to make them construct a certain
way.
And that's why if you look at like the
epic of Gilgamesh,
it's a direct overlay for the
terminator,
right?
I mean,
so there's all these overlaps and nuance
between the ways that we're used to
processing story.
What do you make of the fact that it
seems like the only thing we can
seemingly do right in Hollywood these
days is make superhero movies.
Is there some like extra meaning to that
right now?
Like we're making blockbuster after
blockbuster,
at least marble is just blown it out of
the water with all of these things.
And we don't seem to be making a lot of
new,
original stories anymore.
Well,
I'm a little.
I'm divided on that.
I mean,
my favorite movie last year was wind
river.
I don't know if you saw.
I didn't see that.
Heard of it.
Taylor Sheridan is the writer director.
He also wrote hell or high water and he
wrote a scenario.
Okay.
He's amazing.
So there's interesting work that's being
done.
I mean,
I think there's a preponderance of
superhero stuff because as we are sort
of laying waste to some of the
structures that have protected us in a
lot of ways.
It's sort of the new gods and the new
mythology.
I mean in the case of thor literally.
Right.
And so I think that it,
it,
it's,
it's this overlay for us to contend with
and make meaning with,
with bigger symbols in our life.
I mean,
it's so weird.
I Love Batman,
right?
You're a Batman guy to just by being a
marvel guy.
But it was so funny because I was out
the other day and there was a guy with
like a Batman Wallet and a Batman Tattoo
and a Batman shirt and I was like,
we're grown men.
What are we doing?
What does this mean?
Right?
You have a wallet.
It's sorta like,
is it that different than having a cross
around your neck?
Like why are we,
if you like it,
if you like or comment if you like a
movie,
why are we necessarily like ingraining
that in our skin?
Right.
And having that be on our,
on our,
on our clothes.
Like why would we wear this with a
shield?
I think there's a lot of,
a sort of religious overlay to what
these represent.
Yeah.
Well the stories,
right?
These stories of good and evil and the
way star wars,
at least the originals affected me or,
or the way now.
I mean,
you can get so much truth and
interesting,
deep,
profound psychological,
a thought out of the,
uh,
the original Batman trilogy.
It's incredible.
Well,
it's funny how good and evil and laying
waste to the world.
I mean that heath ledger joker is just
amazing.
Perfection.
Yeah.
Well,
so it's funny.
So you look at,
there's sort of,
we have a direct line with star wars in
some ways because you have a young who
has a fairly impenetrable cannon,
like he's not breathing reading,
you know,
you can read Freud and the studies read
like short stories.
I mean,
so it's obvious for me in hindsight why
studied it,
but things never make sense when you're
just following things that you love.
And I was super interested in
psychoanalysis and in hindsight it's
like of course all young wrote about was
narrative and all Freud wrote about was,
you know,
interesting psychological case studies
which are also narrative based and they
read like short stories.
But so you have a young who's very tough
to penetrate.
So you have Joseph Campbell who came
along,
I think of Campbell is like the cliff
notes for young.
Um,
I don't think Campbell has a lot of
stuff that if you,
you know,
like young's tricky,
he's like reading young takes a lot of
work and focus.
So Campbell makes that more accessible.
And then Campbell had,
you know,
that's where Bill Moyer,
that famous interview,
right?
And Lucas then specifies that makes it
specific in a way and when you're
talking about meaning in stories,
that sort of thing,
it's like no one will deny.
You can find meaning from Freud and
young.
Right?
But when that's distilled down into
something that's specific,
that embodies those principles,
that's the thing that sort of tattooed
on our spinal cords in this culture,
like who didn't have that experience
with Star Wars,
right?
Who doesn't show up with that.
And that's because it's taking these
things that are literally a
philosophical,
psychological meaning making human
beings in,
in,
in these bodies,
in these cannons and distilling it down
to something that everybody can plug
into.
Whether you get it at whatever level,
you get it out,
you get it at.
Seeing those at seven is different than
us seeing them at 30 or 40.
So when Jordan takes that to the
religious place,
did,
do you follow that thinking there?
Yeah,
and I'm from like an atheist Jewish,
you know,
my socialist background,
like I'm not conventionally religiously
ready,
but it's like to deny that a story isn't
that successful.
So here's a weird thing that's always an
issue that I have with,
with Democrats.
I know you get very defensive when
people have problems with Democrats
easier.
There's this funny thing where Democrats
tend to view other cultures with great
reverence,
especially the more exotic they are,
even if there's some fundamental issues
and the other cultures that should be
relevant,
right?
Like you have hardcore feminists who
were supporting certain regimes that
treat women terribly and you're like,
we should jar out of that.
Like that appreciation for the exotic.
And the one thing I find frustrating is
we have such a collection of different
cultures in the United States and it's
like,
why can't you go to Alabama or the deep
south?
I love the deep south.
Like when I sold my first book,
I drove through the deep south to go to
the Bourbon distilleries and a see
faulkner's home.
And why don't you look at that and
people's relationship with the second
amendment and their relationship with
each other and their relationship with
their value system as also being a
culture that is different.
That should be appreciated,
right?
We don't.
It's a weird thing.
And so we do it for the outward world,
but sort of,
it's to be safely exotic.
Right?
But if someone disagrees with you,
and look,
this is true both ways.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not merely beating up Democrats,
but it's a frustration that I've had to
say people think differently.
So if you want to pretend that you're
going jump into their brain and make a
moral judgement on why they hold their
opinions,
that's not good for anybody.
But the same thing holds true for
stories.
It's like going to any university and
it's super cool and hip to talk about
you to analyze the marvel stories or to
analyze star wars.
And it's like,
why wouldn't you do the same with a
story that is so successful that it
dwarfs all of those over centuries and
centuries that his,
you know,
given rise to cathedrals and,
and,
and wars and like,
this is stuff that is moved.
Right,
right,
right.
So it's like if you're into those
stories,
it's like,
ah,
that was,
that was yesterday.
You know,
you're a Jesus freak and it's like,
wait a minute,
like write a story.
Somebody that guys at the star wars
convention.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And it's like,
well,
so what's the story of Jesus like if
you,
if you shoulder your own burden,
if you bear your own cross and accept
your own suffering,
that's the only means toward,
to transforming it or to transcending
it,
I shouldn't say.
And so it's like,
oh,
is that relevant in relationships or
psychology?
Like what's the best approach?
If someone's really screwed up and
complaining and as a murderer in the
whole world,
like you go,
yeah,
I'm honey.
The world's awful.
Like,
is that the parenting that you want?
Or to say what,
what are the things you're doing?
Where are the faults as they exist in
you?
It's one thing that Jews are great on
the Old Testament.
God's angry we screwed up,
right?
Jordan?
Jordan says that a lot.
It's like where is it centered in you
and what is the way that you can accept
the conditions in the inherent tragedy
of life in a way that allows you to
transcend that and it's like that's
played again and again and again.
I mean,
you look at Tony Scott,
Denzel Washington's a man on fire and
it's like you look at how beautifully
that takes an hour in the first act.
Just the relationship between him and
the girl and it's basically a classic
like you need to become a monster to
hunt monsters,
but it's the story of his salvation and
sacrifice for something innocent.
It's just,
it's,
that's my favorite modern movie
probably.
What do you make of the fact that people
actually care about this stuff right
now?
Like this type of conversation and being
able to relate it to either comic books
or movies and still talk about religion
or talk about it from an atheist
perspective that people actually care
about this were I think four years ago
if have a whole bunch of us had been
talking about this,
people will be like,
what the hell?
Like he likes this relevant.
What?
You guys live in your mom's basement?
Well that's what they'd be saying
covered with snack crumbs.
That may well be true,
but I cleaned up before.
I can't remember that.
We appreciate.
So I mean,
I think what's interesting is there's a
letter f Scott Fitzgerald sent to his
editor and it's great because he talks
about all the notes that you get from an
attorney.
He said the American reading public is
totally stupid.
It needs to be led by the nose or number
two,
massively brilliant and can interpret
every problem that you have more like
it's,
it's everything.
It's so morphous view that we always
take toward society and so there's this
view of like the American attention span
is shortening.
You look at it like we went from books
to blogs to kind of my space.
You had to build out to facebook,
to twitter,
to instagram,
like this ever shrinking aspect,
but it's too simplistic.
I mean,
everything's too simplistic,
so we have podcasts,
exploding audio books and publishing
exploding and this sort of longer form
discourse.
I mean,
what I think is really interesting,
this is a lot of people were hungry for
it.
I mean,
I always say to Jordan and it makes no
sense at all that he did a lecture
series on the psychological underpinning
of the Bible and more than three people
showed up like it just.
You wouldn't anticipate that,
but people are a lot smarter and are a
lot more oriented in their desire for
meaning.
Then we give credit.
I can tell you that from being on this
tour with him in the middle,
he'll often say something about how he's
working on the next series of biblical
exteriors.
It gets a huge applause every time.
Like people want more of that.
Absolutely.
Whether they're believers or not.
I think many of the people that watch
them and appreciate them actually aren't
believers,
at least in a traditional sense.
I mean,
and who knows what that means.
Does it,
am I a believer or like do I believe
those stories contain some of the most
fundamental grains of first principles
of orienting oneself in the world?
Absolutely.
So it's like what does it even mean to
be a believer?
But I mean the other thing I find really
interesting with it is that it's sort of
going back to our conversation about
archetypes and my belief that it's
selected is we were sort of meaning
making creatures and so if,
if there's a discussion that Jordan has,
if you guys aren't conversation on a
stage or Eric's arguing with Ben,
right?
You get these opposing views within this
group,
people are engaged in that.
If there,
if it feels like there's a genuine focus
for,
for meaning because it's like that's the
thing that we want more than anything
and it gets hijacked a lot for the
purpose to be like,
oh,
I just want to be happy.
And it's like happiness is temporary and
this is a femoral.
So I think that's what's happening with
these longer form discussions that
people are engaged in is because it
feels like there's something real
happening and it's not buzzwords and
cliches and facile dismissals.
It's,
it's something that's real.
It's almost like also at the same time
mainstream has become so meaningless,
right?
That our ability to just do this and
have a little bit of an exchange maybe
with some differences and some
agreements has that much more value
right now where 10 years ago maybe it
wouldn't have had so much value but the.
But as mainstream careens off into the
abyss.
Well,
we're still here.
it's funny too because in some ways a
reasonable centrist view is now radical,
right?
So if you have a senator who's willing
to compromise and interact with the
other side to pass legislation,
which is one of the tenants of how
Congress had was the right,
that's sort of radical.
Like if you don't only vilify and shut
down from either side and,
and continue to polarize.
And actually,
I,
you know,
part of this,
I've been thinking a lot about how this
has driven with mainstream media and you
and I were talking a little bit about
trying to use the intellectual dark web
is an ability to sort of broaden out
what views are of different parties and
you know,
it's all heterodoxy base,
but like how do we bring in centrist
views and have them represented.
Because one of the things I've been
thinking about a lot,
I've been doing a lot of candidate
training.
I've talked to dozens of candidates from
Tennessee to Alabama,
like all over the country.
Virtually no one that I talked to is
making it a key key aspect of their
platform.
You know,
trans bathrooms in democratic socialism,
literally not a one.
So then it's like,
wait,
is there a role that we're all playing,
you know,
even in this umbrella of the
intellectual,
dark web.
But then the mainstream media,
everyone who's sort of virtue signaling
on social media in starting to think,
you know,
Eric calls it the Chihuahua fact.
I'm like,
there's very loud people who are out at
the edges and like maybe good for them,
right?
Like I'm not in favor of d platforming
anybody on either on either edge,
but there's a huge story in the middle
that I think isn't being told and I
think it's really important to,
to,
to have the Chihuahua fact not cow,
everyone in the middle from being able
to sort of speak up and have the
discourse that they want to have.
One of the things I told,
I sat down with the,
with the Washington Post have sat down
with some other places and said,
look,
count the number of times that you've
written about,
for instance,
it costs ego,
right?
Like,
so she won in a very deep blue district,
like good on her.
Go off in the Bronx and when and see
what,
what's going to work there.
That's not my proclivity,
but I'm not denigrating that.
But it's like how many times have you
written about her verse versus Angie
Craig Halley,
Steven's Joseph crops or Ken Harbor?
All of these amazing former military pro
business,
amazing Democratic candidates.
But I'm guessing that 90 percent of the
people watching,
I haven't heard one of those names and
she said she was all over everything
endlessly for weeks and everyone does
that.
So I've been trying to think about why,
why that is the case,
you know,
I would bet if you go to the New York
Times or the Washington Post,
she's mentioned,
you know,
10 x 20 x these other candidates if not
even more so.
I think from the right it makes sense.
And the left does this too.
So this is not me claiming that the
rights owner who does this,
it makes sense to paint the parties
further left than it is because it's an
easier sort of target to paint the
furthest extreme and then to denigrate
that.
But with the left they're doing it also
I think because there's problems and
they need clickbait and eyeballs.
So I think there's that.
And I think there's also a sort of
curious.
There's a curious desire on the part of
the left sometimes to continue to be
murdered.
Right.
And I don't know if,
if sometimes there's a drive to app to
to further the stories that are stories
that in fact are going to hurt the left.
An example of that is when we talk about
progress that's being made,
there's a lot of progress being made in
race relations for,
for women in business.
There's a propensity for the left to say
everything's bad as it ever was.
Nothing's gotten better and you go
really like you.
Like today it's the same.
Like this is not to say that there isn't
problematic widespread racism,
you know,
but is it really the same as in during,
before the civil rights is really the
same as in Jim Crow,
that nothing's changed and it comes.
I think from a concern that if you can
see that things are better than everyone
will just give up and go home.
There was like a driver to it.
And so I think that there's this aspect
with how the left engages with progress
and what candidates that it looks at
that it's almost.
And I think the right does,
has its own version of this.
There's almost a desire to be constantly
upset and outraged or to constantly be
under the heel of what's viewed as the
other side and what I'm noticing a lot
in the discourse that is the most
advocated or is the most widely spread
is there's.
There's a real sort of martyr mentality
that lies beneath the outrage from
either side.
Okay,
so let's just back up a little bit
better.
So we come from a pretty similar
political backgrounds,
both pretty much democrats our whole
life,
both part of the left,
the whole thing.
I think we differ a little bit now and
that I basically think that ship has
sailed on this thing.
I.
I do think that the left has just rotted
the Democrats from the inside.
I get that there are these good people
and I look forward to having many of
them sit in that very chair and I'll
hope that some things can return,
but I think it's going to get a lot
worse before it gets better.
You're really trying to help the
messaging of this thing,
the focus,
the messaging,
but basically it get rid of some of the
identity politics stuff.
Maybe stop doing so much class warfare
stuff.
I think a few other,
a few other pieces of this convinced me
that a,
it's possible.
Well,
you're right.
First of all that I bet if we sat down
and did a chart of our political views,
I think years in minor,
the closest of anybody in the
intellectual dark web,
like you and I are probably aligned on
everything from gun discipline to
abortion.
Like if you go down the list,
um,
and you're right,
that the biggest difference is like
you've left the party and you and I'm
trying to write.
I haven't joined a new party but just
for the record,
but I don't consider myself a democratic
political.
If that's a party,
I'll join that party.
Yeah.
And I'm trying to kind of refocus the
party in a way that,
that,
that lives up to the promise.
I think it has specifically to when
people like you back.
Yeah,
it's a long road.
There's a lot of hurdles and there's a
lot of quagmires and we have been,
there are a lot of errors that have been
made and I think that one of them is,
I believe that corruption is a very
widespread problem.
I don't think that the Democrats can
continue to make an argument that we're
the less corruptive to parties.
I don't think that's a winning argument.
Yeah.
I think you could probably make the
counter argument pretty easily,
right?
I mean the Democrats did a lot of stuff
against Bernie and,
and Donna Brazil and the questions to
hillary and all sorts of other stuff
that you could argue there are probably
more corrupt and that's,
that might be another.
I don't even think that's an important
argument to have any anymore because I
think put it this way,
let's assume from my perspective,
let's just take the leap to say I
believe the Democrats are less corrupt
than,
than what is happening right now under,
under this administration and some of
the stuff that's going on.
Okay.
Um,
I don't think we can have an argument
that says vote for us were corrupt,
but just kind of lost.
I don't think that's a winning argument.
And I think if we're going to engage
with people like you,
uh,
you know,
Libertarians,
Republicans,
the first thing they're going to say
when it comes to corruption validly.
So it's like,
oh,
you want to clean up corruption.
Okay.
You first.
That's a reasonable first claim for
people who have been in the party and
feel that they're lost.
And so a lot of the hope that I have
with the party or these new candidates
and voices and as part of my dismay
about the way that it's painted that the
far left is what's getting the most
attention or,
or like the ridiculous stuff that
happens on college campuses.
Like a lot of the attention that it's
sort of like claiming that every person
who's on the right is,
is you know,
a radicalized neo Nazi.
It's like,
so where is,
where is the internal push back on that?
Because I can see it this way,
that from someone that was always a
lefty and a Democrat and a progressive,
the whole thing,
and now although I still consider myself
liberal,
I definitely,
if someone sat me for four hours here,
I could probably get to the point where
I'd say I'm a libertarian.
I see ice,
intellectual flexibility on the right.
These days I see a libertarian side,
I see the never trumpers,
I see the trumpers,
I see sort of the Mug lefties.
Like I do see like a couple of different
pillars that are all sort of lefties,
the Mug,
the Mug lefties.
What I would say like I feel like a mug
lefty.
I,
you know that I see like a couple of
different groups that are thought of on
the right right now that differ on
certain things.
But basically you're agreeing to
disagree.
I don't see that on the left,
but you just mentioned a couple of names
that you believe are people will.
Here's the thing,
that's what I think is happening and it
goes to your point about where the
oxygen is,
but if,
if it's,
if there's some evidence of it,
I,
I'd love to see it in here as a,
a trail of candidates.
I mean,
I,
I could list 20 candidates,
which I won't just rattle off,
like you said,
people don't necessarily know,
you know,
Katie Hill and Haley Stevens and Kendra
Horn.
I'm dealing with people everyday who
we're talking about number one thing is
anticorruption and they're signing.
I asked yesterday,
I was at an event with six candidates
and Adam Schiff and I said,
you know,
I've worked with some of them.
I'm working with others.
Instead of all of you signed on the
disclose act,
disclose act is vowing to a name
lobbyists,
all lobbyist influence.
It's all to get money out of politics,
which I,
which I think is the number one issue
isn't business.
It's,
it's sort of the donor class level and
influence of lobbyists.
Like I think that's a really big
problem.
Um,
and do you disclose everybody?
You disclose your donors,
which I'm going to talk more about from
a libertarian perspective in a second
because we had a very interesting
conversation with Ben that shifted some
of my thinking on that.
Lobbyists,
right?
You going to name all your lobbyists,
are you going to come out for protection
of the vote no matter what?
Right?
Are you going to come out hard against
taking pac money for individual
candidates or like bombing the other
side through a pack,
a anti Gerrymandering,
right?
Which means either a bi partisan
committee that does it,
which has some problems or judicial or
I'm increasingly starting to think about
that.
There was a congress congressional fix,
like if you're really great job,
Congress doing a lot more.
Imagine if they did anything right,
so it's swearing a bunch of things
before they're going forward.
There's dozens and dozens of names on
the list of people who have signed onto
this call is to act and I believe
they're all democrats.
They're all younger Democrats.
Would this wave.
Now the disclosed thing is troubling for
me because you get stupid stuff like,
um,
this in and out,
a boycott that lasted a day and a half,
which if people aren't familiar with it,
I think somebody called it,
they found out the in and out had
donated to Republicans and called for a
boycott and the best thing in southern
California,
everyone's like,
dude,
that's in and out,
like,
sorry,
not happening.
But then they found out that they'd
given money to Democrats and like the
whole thing is this mass.
And so and I understand and things are
also complicated.
Like Nike Right now has Colin
Kaepernick's the face of that,
they're calling him a $6,000,000,000
man.
They rent the ground floor of trump
tower for $13,000,000
a year.
Okay.
They've given three times as much money
to Republicans and Democrats.
So it's like who are we boycotting?
And meanwhile there's a sandwich chain
that just got put out of business
because the owner took a picture with
trump,
right?
So it's like from both sides,
it's like,
what are we doing?
Everyone's burning there Nike's,
but they're actually paying $30,000,000
to rent space and are giving three act.
Right?
They're using sweatshops in China or
Vietnam or wherever and now suddenly
everyone on the left school with that
because they want to support Nike
because right in the eds,
but also everybody in the right is sort
of outraged by this move and they're
burning their shoes.
But Nike also was given three act.
It's like let's not look for our moral
guidance maybe from corporations.
Like maybe that's a good.
So that that's it.
I would say not your moral guidance nor
from politicians.
I don't think we should be getting it
from politicians or.
I mean people look at politicians now as
if they're supposed to be superheroes
and they're just people who are middle
management pushing things one way or
another a little bit,
but instead we want people to come in
with magical powers and fix things that
haven't been able to be fixed for all of
humanity.
I mean,
I think there are certain standards to
which we want politicians held.
Like we want doctors and lawyers.
There are certain oats of the office.
If someone's life is being run by
lobbyists,
it's like that's a problem,
but to go back just real quickly to
that,
to that concern,
which is if you just close everything,
then people can kind of mob you and
boycott you,
and we've seen that from both sides in a
way that just becomes a mess.
And then companies like my one of my
biggest protest actually isn't a moral.
It's that it makes everything boring.
It just makes it so dull that anytime
somebody takes her,
you're a comedian.
Guests what you live on the edge,
if you live on the edge,
you're going to say stuff.
Sometimes it doesn't play or stuff
that's offensive.
Look at Richard Pryor.
Look at Eddie Murphy.
Look at Dave Chappelle.
You know you're a comedian.
I mean the whole game is to do that and
maybe you're going to miss and fall down
and then got a cell phone in the in the
crowd waiting,
just waiting to click send and then
there's that word,
craven nonsense.
Apologies to who?
Who is,
who is like curled in a fetal position
in their shower scrubbing themselves
because Dave Rubin made a joke that was
mean about something like I just don't.
Who are you,
who do people apologize too?
But so one of the things,
and,
and I know that this is an issue.
I mean this is one of the other things I
know that disclosing is a problem from a
libertarian perspective because why
shouldn't people just give money and
let's say that somebody in La and
they're Christian and they give money to
a pro family,
anti gay marriage group.
It's like maybe they don't want to be
out and if it means they're never going
to work again.
Um,
and so I understand those concerns.
And so one of the things that I'm sort
of discussing and advocating is to raise
the floor of that to some number and I
don't know what it is,
but these are conversations that are
being had internally.
And obviously the Democratic Party is
the one pushing all this.
This is not my invention,
but this is something that I find to be
important with the candidates who were
running to talk about,
but maybe there's some floor where we
say,
look,
5,000
or $10,000
give what you want and it's secret,
but if you're giving over $10,000,
you want to be political player and
maybe have the spine to stand behind
your money then and I know that that's
not like I will concede that that is
running against the current of what a
libertarian argument would be,
but when I'm weighing that against,
you know,
millions of dark money that no one knows
where it's from.
If it's in the country,
out of the country going up to take out
candidates.
Like that's,
that's a sacrifice that I'm,
I'm interested in making.
Yeah.
Well that's one of those middle ground
things that I think is worth having the
conversation about because I don't.
I'm not someone that would say there
should be no government involvement in
any of their shirt,
so you have to figure out,
all right,
you're going to be a real player in
this.
Then maybe that does have to disclose
that.
That actually does make sense to me.
Unfortunately this isn't where you get a
lot of headlines of,
oh,
people are trying to figure out what
the,
what the fair balances on what to
disclose,
but wouldn't it be cool?
You know,
it's like we have this thing and it's
one of the things I talked so much about
messaging.
You walk into a big rally,
you say,
I believe universal healthcare is a
right.
Everyone's immediately in their camp
like,
yeah,
and there's cheering and it's wonderful.
Or like there's no way I worked so hard
my whole life.
I paid for my own healthcare.
Why can't people do it?
And what you just said about there's a
reasonable ground in the middle.
Um,
and these are conversations I think that
are essential.
It's like everything's in the middle.
It's like,
okay,
well,
you know,
we think everyone should have some
standard of healthcare so people aren't
dying in the streets in America,
right?
That's an American and it's unethical.
It's also a massive public health issue.
If people just die in their bodies are
rotting and Mr also paying for it either
way.
Exactly.
So like still it's an economic argument
like let's not pretend,
let's not fight over an abstract notion
of whether universal healthcare is a
right or a privilege like that doesn't
actually do anything for people who need
healthcare.
So instead do we look at it and go,
okay,
average cost of an emergency room visit
is $1,233
hospital passes onto an insurance
company who passes it on to us because
they're uninsured and our rates go up or
vaccination is $19.
So let's have some dollars and cents
discussions and let's also talk to
people from around the table even who we
might disagree with about how we get
into that.
And it was interesting because I was on
with Jordan when we jumped on the phone
with Ben when I was talking through some
of this stuff about like,
like I was trying to figure out if
there's any good argument for
gerrymandering.
Aside from the fact that everyone from
either party just gets to keep their
jobs.
So why would you literally the points of
interest to me is to call someone like
you and be like,
make an argument for gerrymandering so I
can know what it is.
And so I was kind of having this
conversation and,
and you know,
getting pushback from Ben about this
disclosure thing for exactly the in and
out reasons and it's like,
okay,
well he and I aren't going to agree,
you know,
it's like he's,
he's gonna see his,
his opinion is get all money out of
government and then no one's going to
compete for it.
It's a very different solution to the
one that I advocate.
But in hearing that I think there's a
way to,
to address concerns that reasonable
people will have to say I want to give
to $2,500
through candidate.
I don't want the whole neighborhood to
know like what if it's more liberal and
I'm in Alabama,
right?
What if it's more conservative and I'm
in San Francisco and so the ways to sort
of hear where people are coming from and
try to figure out ways to discuss that.
And so the biggest hope when you said to
convince me for me is this next
generation of leadership in the
Democratic Party.
There is amazing.
You know,
there's a Guy Joseph Kopser in Texas who
20 years he was an army ranger,
a professor at West Point,
went to the Kennedy School,
got a degree,
started his own business,
you know,
created hundreds of jobs for people in
Texas and is now running for a seat.
Interesting guy,
very common sense geared,
goes into churches,
goes into Republican strongholds and
sits down and we'll have a conversation
with anybody could sit here and hold his
own with you.
So this does show why the media or the
way they frame all this is so much of
the problem because no one has heard of
any of these people.
And if you control the information that
we're getting,
we're shifting the views on the party.
And I feel the same way an inverse about
trump voters.
Like you're,
you're hearing from them.
And people are saying it's,
it's guys with torches at midnight
protecting confederate statues.
And it's like,
wait a minute,
I have an incredibly wide array of
friends.
I have a very broad cross section of
friends who voted for trump and it's too
widespread for me to dismiss everybody
as being mouth breathing troglodytes.
There's no way.
I've very smart friends.
I have friends who were in the military,
there are a bunch of people made
different decisions.
There's people who think that we need
anything as long as it wasn't another
Bush or another Clinton,
I don't care what it is.
They wanted a disruption.
And I think that it's really important.
Look at the way that the media is
tailoring that.
And part of what I think our job is are
people like us,
is to sort of cut through that and to
try and have a conversation about what's
really going on.
And for me,
with the Democrats,
it's like I can,
as I said,
I mean have people sit down or look at
it,
Angie Craig or Kendra Horn or you know,
can harbaugh's someone I just spoke with
last week,
you know,
another guy was in the military,
didn't emergency relief a organization
afterwards health 80,000
people like you talk to him.
He's talking about healthcare and jobs
and education.
And when you say that most of these
folks are against identity politics and
just sort of the general state of when
people talk about the left,
what it's become.
Would you say that they're in opposition
to what I think are most of the
concerning part of the left?
The concerning parts?
Yes.
I mean what's hard is at least the parts
that we seem to be concerned about,
let's put it that way.
Here's what's hard with identity
politics is,
it's one of these terms that means very
different things to different people.
Right?
So some people are like identity and
that you know,
like I'm African American and have an
issue with actual statistics on
imprisonment rates or police brutality
and ways that that skews is one thing
saying you can't have cultural
appropriation and I'm melting down over
white male privilege because you know,
Justin timberlake has a braiding,
his hair is another thing and all of
those are sort of different and chopped
up and it's like I like for me,
nobody,
like I haven't had one conversation
about trans bathrooms or white male
privilege or any of these things with
the candidates.
It doesn't mean that they are not more
inclined based on their political
orientation and their big five
personality traits.
Right?
Or empathy,
higher openness to have sympathy for
those arguments or the arguments that
are beneath those arguments where people
are coming from.
But the very far left stuff about it
like a day without white people at
Evergreen.
The brass.
No,
I'm not hearing that stuff anywhere.
So it gets a little tricky because for
me I feel like we can't have it be that
all immigration is bad or all
integration is good.
Like you were talking about meeting in
the middle with stuff.
It's like everyone in this country is
the descendant of an immigrant
basically.
Yeah.
Unless you were native American or,
or brought here.
And we also can make an argument that
all immigration is good.
So maybe if we could put down those bats
that were beating each other with and
actually sit down and talk to what the
concerns are.
It could be a conversation.
He said something very interesting about
when you were on with banner.
Ben was on with you.
I don't remember.
We were talking about abortion and
you're,
you support choice.
Um,
I consider myself begrudgingly pro
choice and I cut off basically.
Yeah.
But it's like you,
you conceded,
which I thought was really interesting
because I'm always trying to look at
this issue and to approach an issue
that's incredibly emotional with like,
it actually is an issue with very good
people on both sides.
Well that's the abortion was the most
interesting to me because it's so
obvious that sides have
a principled position to start.
One doesn't want to control the woman's
body.
One doesn't want,
one wants to make sure that this child
is taken care of it and has the right to
life and all that,
so it's like if we can at least
acknowledge that now we can start
discussing some of the science,
we can start discussing some of the
social responsibility of government and
everything else
before we get into trouble is when we
impugn the motives of another side
because nobody knows.
We don't even know our own motives half
the time.
So for me to say,
you just said that,
let me tell you what your moral failings
are.
Let me tell you where you're not in
command of your own,
you know,
moral nature to be flawed to make this
argument right.
Anytime we get that from the other
side's the reaction is obviously like a
highest men into that.
But what you said that I thought was the
most courageous thing that you said and
I think it's the.
I think it is the,
it's the,
the tectonic plate under which we can
sort of build solutions.
As you said,
look,
I can seed that.
Part of my argument is arbitrary.
Like how about,
what'd you say?
Twenty,
20 weeks,
so obviously weeks in a day.
How about if she's raped and she's going
to die,
but it's 21 weeks there.
There it is.
We have to concede that we are not
absolute in our views and some things
are absolute for people,
but it's like when we're talking about
immigration,
right?
When we're talking about gun discipline,
it's like there's certain stuff where if
you go in same thing where everyone
raise your hand who's for gun control?
Everyone's going to immediately go into
their two camps,
but you can go in and say,
look guys,
politicians and the media always want to
make it seem like this is an all or
nothing proposition that anything that's
a slippery slope.
We're going to just slide all the way to
the bottom,
right?
If we make any impingement on,
on second amendment rights that
everyone's going to take our guns away
and the other side is like,
hey,
anything that you come for me for this,
if I give any ground,
it's going to get worse.
And everybody's really entrenched in
that and it's like we're already on a
slippery.
So what do you think we need to break
that because it seems to me that I'm
with you.
We've got these two sides kind of going
and polar opposite directions.
You know,
I've spent more time talking about one
side that I used to be part of because
that's where I was.
But I get it.
We've got two sides doing this partially
scoring lover thing to do.
You do that?
Well,
that's why I said mugged left the year
before.
I think I'm Bret Weinstein said that I
have,
I have ptsd basically,
but whatever,
whatever it is you,
you,
when you're a part of something,
you can recognize it there.
And look,
if 10 years from now,
if I'm hanging out with all these
libertarians and they're all crazy,
I'll,
I'll call them out.
You know what I mean?
Like I just think it's just human
nature.
You can go to what you know and where
you were.
It's almost like we need something crazy
to happen.
I don't even know what I mean by this.
Exactly.
To break this thing,
we can talk about it rationally,
right.
And the whole idw crew can talk about
how to have these conversations and
agree to disagree and I,
you know,
ben and the,
the gay cake and all that.
Like I can try to hopefully he'll make
me a cake one day now that I think he's
in particularly good baker,
but like we can do that for the next 50
years,
that discussion.
But it almost seems to me we're on this
like slide to something
really horrible.
Is gonna happen.
I again,
I don't know exactly what I mean,
but it's like what would it take to wake
people up to this?
We're all talking about it and no one's
actually stopping it from happening.
Well,
the inevitable descent I think in a
weird way when everyone's looking at the
sort of trump phenomenon,
right?
Which came out of nowhere seemingly but
really didn't part of the vote for him
and for you know,
a 70 something year old democratic
socialist from Vermont I think was that.
I think it was a reaction to that.
The people said the status quo isn't
going to work anymore.
Like I said,
I don't care who it is,
it's not going to be another Bush
Clinton,
and you know,
I might,
I might disagree with the choices that
some people made,
but I can't disagree with the driving
anger and frustration that underlay
that.
And,
and you know,
Eric talks about the sort of three big
lies that have been put forth,
you know,
one is that all immigration is good,
right?
The other is that would trade a rising
tide lifts all ships.
The third is that there is zero
connection whatsoever between terrorism
and Islam,
that they're totally unhooked.
I add a fourth though,
Eric thinks it's less relevant,
but I think that it's the argument that,
um,
that biology has no basis whatsoever in
gender definition or in,
in,
you know,
sexuality,
that there's,
that,
that seems like a huge one these days.
Mean Eric believes that that's less wide
spread.
But I think that culturally that,
that position is so weaponizing that I
think that that's an equivalent one.
And I think that what you're seeing is a
reaction to these absolutes that
everybody knows that a gut level aren't
true and it's like everybody's
entertaining them on the surface.
Everybody's having a conversation,
which is,
you know,
I believe only an open borders or I
believe we have to shut down borders
and,
and separate families.
And then it's like,
these polls are so crazy and I think
that they're both groups are motivated
to protect their further left or right
compatriots.
I mean,
so we're having this movement that's
going out in that direction.
But I think that's what it was a
reaction to.
And I think you're saying,
look,
where's the point of the Big Bang theory
that the university,
you know,
explodes that it starts to come back
together and because I'm afraid it's
going to have to take something
horrible.
And again,
I don't even know what I mean.
Is there going to be like some
terrorists deck or something that will
just remind us that these people are not
all of our enemies.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like,
I don't want to think of the world that
you were saying essentially what that
thesis is to say if there's a horrible
terrorist attack,
the new sort of outgroup threat will get
Americans back together because nobody
wants that to happen of course.
And there's huge danger and what that
ends up leading to because we know how
we sort of went crazy after nine slash
11 and the Patriot Act and all that.
But like it just seems to me that the,
the wheels on this thing,
although now people are talking about
it,
it's not slowing down and that just
leads me to believe it gets to the ledge
to.
Well I think the first thing is,
is you know,
like clean up your own kitchen first.
I mean that's what I'm doing.
If the guy that I'm on tour with,
it's doing something about cleaning up
your own.
But see I switched into kitchen.
That was.
No,
that was effective.
It's yours.
Jordan got everything.
He knows I'm boiling.
Wait,
let's pause there for a second.
Just real quick because we shouldn't
have totally dismissed this.
So you were in Jordan student?
I was,
what,
what was that like?
Well,
we'll get back there,
but let's just not because I wanted to
do it like 20 minutes ago and Jordan was
amazing.
I mean,
I love Jordan from minute one.
He taught me,
um,
personality psychology.
I went back into the young seminar with
him and then he was,
my thesis advisor is like,
what?
Mid Nineties?
Early nineties.
I graduated in 95 and he was dynamite.
He was very imposing and formal.
I just like,
right away was,
was,
was like I just got to solve the whole
thing and I remember telling my college
roommates,
I was like,
that's a guy who's going to be
remembered just by his last name,
like Hundred Years after his dad and you
know,
I didn't quite think it was because he
was going to be doing,
you know,
kermit the frog.
Hitler means.
But like whatever.
I mean I just thought in an academic
arena.
Yeah,
he's sort of brilliance for me was.
And his pattern recognition and ability
to boil stuff down.
But he would even then,
if somebody came in ideologically from
the left or the right and it was kind of
a hollow shell,
he would just puncture it,
didn't have as much of a,
of a,
of.
He was formidable.
I mean he wasn't as joking.
I mean obviously we're,
we're good friends now,
but he was,
you know,
he could be intimidating to other
people,
but I always just really liked him.
And then we stayed in touch after that.
He was my thesis advisor.
We're very close and then he officiated
my wedding.
So I,
I'm the only person on record to have a
wedding that like sites extensively from
Canaan,
evil,
everyone,
I assume the Gulag archipelago needs.
We had little like Gulag archipelago,
like table settings.
No,
but at one point my wife and I just re
watched our wedding video was so funny
and she's looking and you know,
she adores Jordan to and Jordan was
going off about something and she,
she's looking up at me and she's in her
dress like where that moment at the
altar.
And she said,
this is the part where I wasn't sure if
I was getting married or being treated
like they're Jordan did a whole
archetypical analysis and then,
you know,
look,
I put his rules for life in orphan acts
as a,
as a I have like the assassins 10
commandments and I wanted to actually
good rules that,
that someone could be raised by.
And then I helped him,
you know,
edit the book and work on the book from
the early stage.
So I read it and had an orphan x three
years before his book came out.
So when you,
when you say that when people would come
in with arguments from either side and
he could just pop them just like that.
That's one of the most interesting
things to me because if you listen again
to what mainstream is saying about him
is that he's this,
he's this ultra conservative or this
forest monogamy or he doesn't like gay
people are just like any of this
nonsense.
Which every night I hear him go up there
and beat these arguments down.
He beats down the arguments of identity
politics on the right.
I mean,
he's literally,
every criticism of him is like the
reverse of what he's actually doing
doesn't mean he's right about
everything,
but it's not,
you know,
everyone is deserving of criticism,
but it should be legit criticism.
So it must infuriate you when you read
some of these things about him knowing
that,
you know,
this is,
this isn't the guy that you learned
here.
Yeah.
And you meanwhile he brings like a gay
guy on tour with him.
He's a crazy Christian homophone.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
one of the jokes I have,
he got accused of being an antisemite at
some point and um,
it was so great.
Eric and I were talking about this and I
think I tweeted,
I'm like,
boy,
you know,
Jordan did a terrible job covering up
his antisemitism when he officiated my
wedding 15 years ago.
Most incompetent anti-semite I've ever
met.
Um,
you know,
it's more infuriating for me.
I,
I feel like the media skew is so
complicated.
I've almost given up on us in,
in certain ways.
I look,
I think the media has done an amazingly
impressive stuff.
Like I'm,
I'm a big fan of the Washington Post
despite how some things have gone,
so it's like I'm not,
I'm not giving up on that.
I don't.
I believe that the media is doing a
really good job on cultural issues.
I'm accustomed to it when people come in
and attack Jordan for being right.
It's like there is a video online of him
denouncing the alt right for an hour if
you bothered to look into it.
The thing that infuriates me more
seemingly intelligent intellectual
people who will dismiss him or get
nervous if I bring his name up based on
anything that is wildly taken out of
context.
And with Jordan it's like,
look,
I was a student.
I've known him a lot of years.
I've seen hundreds and hundreds of hours
of his lectures both in school and here.
You know,
I,
I helped him with his book when he was
going through the book and he makes fun
of me for that and the acknowledgements.
There's nothing that he has said that I.
I mean I know his work about as well as
anyone could.
There's not a single thing that he said
that if you don't contextualize,
it doesn't actually make sense and I
have people wholesale say,
Oh,
well I have my feelings about that.
It's like,
you know,
I,
I'll mentioned doing something with him
and people who are,
who are seemingly academic and I'll say,
did you read the book
just,
is that just the plight of doing
something that is something close to
true?
I mean when I'm out there with him every
night and he changes the speed,
you know,
he does an hour and a half.
I'm warm.
The crowd up.
He does an hour and a half and then we
do like 40 minutes together at the end,
but that hour and a half he does.
He changes it every night.
I see him searching for truth every
night and it's like,
well actually all this hatred and all of
that non contextualized stuff that
you're talking about is just,
that's just the shitty part of doing
something good.
Right.
Maybe like,
isn't that if you were writing the
character,
wouldn't you be doing dealing with all
this?
It's so interesting.
So.
All right,
so two things like who's gonna say
something true and then it's going to be
all good.
Everybody's going to love him.
I like it.
Worked out for Jesus.
Didn't work out that well for the earth
isn't the center right,
so I was thinking that brought up two
kind of ideas for me.
I mean one of them is people who were
seemingly academic and intelligent and
pride themselves on being cerebral.
It's like how dare you denigrate him
because you read an unflattering profile
and not read a book or listen to a
lecture or do any research beyond that,
but they got it in the New York Times.
Well,
right.
I mean or in any host of other places
that have missed the mark and then the
New York Times will come around and do
something flattering.
I mean a profiles,
a profile and they take a point of view
but like dig deeper.
But what's so interesting is you were
just talking about that and that it is
such a cool thing to watch him just like
you're watching somebody grappling with
issues when he's on stage and you've
watched him do that a lot.
It reminds me a bit of like the,
the abstract expressionists.
I was just thinking like we're,
we're pollock started to say the act of
creation is a triumph,
right?
So what I'm going to paint something,
you're going to see my brush stroke,
right,
that's laid on on canvas and of course
linkedin.
She did a great kind of piss take on
that where he did like a carefully
painted cartoon version of that.
But where you really are seeing the work
and that the work is what is the
abstract expressionists really sort of
put the art world on their head by
elevating the form and the function for
like the heroism of the crater.
So it's sort of interesting because I
haven't,
I,
I've noted of course that he's grappling
with things and part of him thinking
about is what's appealing.
Like the thing that I said that I keyed
to with you is saying,
look,
part of my argument for pro choice is
arbitrary.
It has to be we're so used to not
conceding any of that,
so to see somebody stand up in front of
3000 people and go hang on,
like,
and really be reasoning with that in a
way that you might reach in a bag and
come up with nothing is compelling and
there's something heroic about that.
The way the Jackson pollock was
portraying.
So as a writer you want to create
characters that show vulnerability
because it shows that they're human and
yet we seem to operate in a time when
almost no one is showing vulnerability
outwardly.
Our politicians don't want to show it or
media people like everyone wants to be
perfect every,
all the virtue signaling these days.
Everyone wants to be like this perfect
thing.
So then you get the few people that show
a little vulnerability and I guess that
has a little extra value.
Hmm,
that's a good point.
I mean we tend to question there,
just the point.
Yeah.
Well I see.
It's interesting because we see a lot of
photo vulnerability,
right?
Like when it's masking virtue signaling,
like I've been thinking about this other
notion that I have,
which is,
you know,
in writing,
because it's sort of like why am I doing
all this stuff and politics,
right?
Like,
nothing makes sense.
So I looked back on,
like when I was like,
why would I study,
you know,
shakespearian tragedy,
young and Freud,
and it's like,
oh,
that's,
that's thrillers,
right?
That's everything that I love.
But likewise with politics,
it's like when you're writing,
well,
what you want to avoid is cliche.
Like it's like your podcast,
like what you don't want to do is do
like whatever,
what you're supposed to say,
everything about you and what you do is
not saying what everyone else says and
not lowering yourself to cliche.
So in books,
you,
that's what you search for,
right?
If there's an obvious plot turn right,
you have the cops sitting outside of the
guy being like,
this is my last day till retirement and
I'm going to buy a yacht and sail around
the world.
You're like,
that guy's getting killed,
like everything we try and do is avoid
that.
Yeah.
So in politics,
so much of what I'm doing is trying to
make people speak humanly and to avoid
buzzwords and so it's like I have this
theory that like as soon as you talk
about,
you know,
a woman's right to choose that doesn't
feel like it's sufficiently complex and
motivated.
I understand people need to,
we need to gravitate with shorthand.
But like I remember growing up in the
Reagan era family of like,
you know,
we were the only Jews in Saratoga and
Silicon Valley in my neighborhood at the
time and the only people who voted
Democrat,
you know,
it was early days of Silicon Valley,
so diverse now,
but that was all the,
like Hewlett Packard engineers who look
like the launch guys from NASA,
the glasses and the pocket protector.
It was just,
it was totally geared that way.
Retail is not thrilled with the
diversity in silicon valley,
but that's a different issue.
Dot Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
he's not thrilled with the diversity of
thought,
but you were talking about the
university is getting code of thought.
Where was.
I lost my thread.
You guys were the outliers when you were
growing up there.
Oh right.
And so everybody was talking about
family values.
That was a big political thing from the
rice and I'm sure you had a bit of a
reaction to that too,
of like,
well I want to talk about family values
and I just felt like,
what do you feel like it's such a
Republican word that coded for all this
stuff for me?
And I was naturally very resistant to
it.
So then I grew up,
I get married,
I have two kids and I'm like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
I should have family values,
family values.
Like I like this new light because the
word was co-opted as a catchphrase and
when Republicans were using it,
there it one time it had a rich and body
of meaning.
But when it's used again and again and
again and again in a campaign,
it loses all the life to it.
And the same thing happens with liberal
slogans.
And so it's almost like the process of
compressing information into newsworthy
soundbites and using phrases and catch
phrases the further you are from genuine
or authentic thought and it's a very
similar thing of where you're trying to
reach in and do things differently in
novels or in screenwriting or Comex,
um,
is very similar thing to the stage.
It's like,
don't just shovel out a bunch of
cliches.
Like,
oh,
Democrats are all for redistribution of
wealth.
It's like,
no,
that's not what all democrats are for.
Republicans are all,
you know,
racist and scared of outsiders.
It's like,
no,
that's not what all Republicans are.
And so the more that we hear things that
we've heard again and again and again,
the further we're off the mark,
and maybe that's why this expansive
format you know,
is,
is what's leading to more complicated
things because we're not,
we don't have two minutes to just sort
of hurl the cliches at each other.
So if I'm,
if we're looking forward a little bit to
the elections that are about to happen,
these midterms now,
it seems to me that for,
for the decent Democrats,
trying to retain some of what old
liberalism and old democratic messaging
was,
there's a really tough position here
because it seems to me that if the
Democrats win,
it means that the further left wing of
the party wins right now.
Is that,
is that a fair estimation?
I don't know.
I don't think that's right.
So because you think that these sort of
unknown people.
Yeah.
People.
I mean,
so it's like tell me the candidates who
you know,
to be hardcore laugh.
Well here's the reason I'm asking you is
that if,
if the argument is that these far left,
these are going to win.
Well then there's no reason to have a
reformation of the Democratic Party.
They're going to go,
all right,
Greg Sia,
you know,
our far left.
He's one.
If the Republicans win and then that
sort of far left thing implodes,
then there's a huge amount of space for
you.
If you're,
if what you're saying is there is this
huge groundswell of people that nobody's
heard of who are more moderate sort of
blue dog,
they're rejecting some of this socialism
stuff that's,
that's a hopeful story there that I
haven't heard too much.
Oh yeah.
Well I'm more sanguine about this
because I feel like just like we talked
about people dismissing Jordan because
they read a New York Times profile or
like whatever the head pieces of the guy
who talked about him romancing the
salvage,
like there's horrible stuff that's out
there,
but they haven't actually read his book
or they haven't seen an actual lecture
or they haven't read an opposing piece.
Even if you only want to read profiles,
so it's like maybe read a flattering one
if you hold yourself to be an
intellectual before dismissing him as a
pseudo scientists,
which is absolutely absurd.
Given his academic record,
like maybe take a more,
a bigger position.
Same thing is happening in some ways
with politics and like,
I don't ever want to put people on the
spot,
but it's like,
you know,
I always feel like name a bunch of
congressional candidates and people are
like,
I'm Rossio and across you it's like
people,
that's not what we're reading.
That's not the water we're swimming in.
And so to really have a conversation we
have to go outside of the profiles
about,
you know,
you being an old writer and Jordan being
whatever Jordan is this week.
It's amazing.
The things.
It's incredible.
Again,
know we need to go out and dig into
that.
And that's the thing where I can say
I've spent,
you know,
at this point,
hundreds of hours with the party and
finding.
And I don't know all this stuff,
like I'm not a natural politician,
but I'm going to talk to people to go,
here's what I think we need to sort of
unify the party,
you know,
under the values that I think that we've
had in the past and need to improve on
in the future.
Especially with the anticorruption.
And here's the way that we need to talk
about issues that they can see that the
other side is human and that we don't
have a magical ball to judge them and to
judge all of their moral shortcomings.
And what I'm finding again and again and
again and again,
is that these candidates are amazing,
but there's sort of no reason unless you
really go digging that you would have
heard of them because no one's doing
that.
And that's part of why I,
you know,
I called you to enlist you in my eval
project and I was like,
look,
you and I agree on almost everything.
Let me get some people on here to talk
to you so that you can see that that's,
that's in fact like 90 percent of the
party.
Well,
that's the thing.
I care how this story ends as long as I
remain true to myself.
So if,
if you succeed,
right?
And the messaging of this succeeds,
and five years from now I'm proud to be
a Democrat again.
If that even matters in the labeling
process or whether I'm,
wherever else I am,
as long as I'm true to myself,
that's what I care about,
but like it's like man,
get to it and make this thing work and
that,
that would be great.
Well,
and I should also make,
make abundantly clear,
like I don't mean in any way to imply
that I'm somehow like the magical
steering.
No,
no,
I got you.
I mean,
you.
Yeah.
But I mean that's what I'm trying to do.
So I'm doing my part of that.
But obviously there's a lot of political
leadership.
There's a lot of people working on it.
My team is,
you know,
includes Marshall Herskovitz and Kenny
Corey,
like we have a lot of people who are
engaged in this.
So,
um,
but I mean,
your point holds,
I just realized I don't,
I don't want to sit here and pretend
like I'm,
I'm the unique message or the party,
but I had been putting in a lot of time
and I think I see things in a way.
Um,
I have a pretty broad range of friends
and associates and I think I can really
see things well from different
perspectives.
Like if there,
if there is,
you know,
another talent that I would claim
besides typing,
you know,
it might be that,
that like I'm,
I'm glad and empowered to have
conversations with people like you where
you're,
where you have concerns that are
different than mine and a real genuine
curiosity to kind of go,
what are poke called poke holes in this.
Here's what I'm thinking.
Tell me everything that's dumped because
that'll give me a big benefit when I
have to go sell it internally and
certainly when we go out in the real
world because then you're naked.
So if I can enlist people who think
differently and see the world
differently to really beat up ideas that
I might have it,
it's like that's just silly.
That's like wandering out into the mob
naked,
you know?
So I'm,
I'm,
that's just something that's always
intrigued me.
Yeah,
that's a pretty solid input.
Alright.
I think unless you got something better
than that,
but that was that.
We kind of wrapped it nicely there.
Yeah.
Well,
before I deteriorate into
inarticulateness,
maybe we'll just.
We'll call it a day.
All right.
We're going to do more on comic books
next time I think we should do all comic
book.
We should just totally geek out and
you'll have like three viewers like your
podcast low will get super.
Yeah.
Well maybe you'll get a whole bunch of
other.
Yeah.
You just shift audiences.
That's true.
It's all the people who we associate
with are not going to be interested
back.
That's all right.
It's been a pleasure,
man.
For more on Greg,
follow him on twitter.
It's Greg,
two g's or width.